over the past 12 months UK content
creator Perry carial has more than
quadrupled in her following why well
it's actually quite simple she plays
video games with her
mind technically technically hell yeah
that counts right so how did Perry even
get here how exactly does she do what
she does and what does it mean for the
future of
Gaming
[Music]
Innovation is at the heart of the gaming
and Esports industry whether it's how we
make the games or how we play them
everyone is waiting for that next big
thing but rarely do we ever talk about
the people behind the advancements the
ones who put in the hours the ones who
search for New Paths and go further than
ever before the people that start with a
simple idea like what if we didn't use
controllers to play video games but mind
control meet Perry caral a British
Canadian twitch streamer with a masters
in Psychology and an act for wacky
projects involving the brain such
projects include conversations on human
psychology experiments in fear and most
notably playing video games with unusual
[Music]
peripherals in January of 2023 Perry
started going viral online for using
different types of tech to game things
like ey tracking gyro and most Paramount
an EEG but attaching electrodes to her
head to play Elden ring wasn't the
original plan for Perry's streaming
career in fact she got into content
creation for a completely different
reason so when I first started streaming
it was actually because I wanted to be a
standup comedian and at that time I was
studying music so it was completely
completely so far removed from the stuff
that I'm doing now um and I just yeah I
started playing games because that's
what you do when you stream and that's
kind of the whole thing but the reason
why I do psychology style gaming stuff
now is because uh I was doing the random
gaming the full guys and all of that
stuff and then I accidentally stumbled
upon games like the Quantic dream games
and Stanley par and I sort of started
thinking hey you know gaming can be
really interesting and can kind of
combine the interest that I have in
Psychology and in neuroscience and okay
let's see where we can take this on top
of having a music degree Perry's Masters
in Psy ology focused on things like
Visual and auditory perception with her
eventual dissertation diving into how
video games could potentially improve
people's vision and recognition and once
these connections between her formal
education and gaming grew stronger Perry
streams took on a new identity she began
talking to her chat about topics in
neuroscience and psychology especially
in relation to things like horror games
and how fear can affect our brains this
eventually led to Perry incorporating an
EEG an EEG or pams uses electrodes
attached to the scalp to measure things
like brain activity and there's been
plenty of uses in the greater medical
field from diagnosing epilepsy to sleep
disorders but Perry discovered that you
can just straight up buy your own
Bluetooth EEG headset charged by USB and
once she did she had a novel idea hey
what if I showed people the effects on
brain activity after a video game jump
scare and it was through that idea that
Perry developed another idea I sort of
just kept trying to push one step
further what can I do what can I do and
with these eegs these electrograms and
these uh softwares you can make it
remember your part in of brain activity
and as course of course if you've like
done any sort of coding or anything like
that you know if you can have a if you
have a software that can record
something and recognize something and
there's any sort of machine learning
involved you can have it so that it can
keybind or be key binded to something
that's something that Perry had in mind
was controller inputs if an EEG Maps
brain activity could she teach software
to pick up repeated brain signals as
buttons on a controller to punch a tree
in Minecraft or cast a spell in Elden
ring turns out the answer is yes
although it took a lot of trial and
error Perry could eventually map out
multiple buttons and with the help of
eye tracking and Gyro controls to help
with other tasks she eventually was
playing games with her mind it is mind
control um basically what it does is
it's a bunch of these senses that sit on
your head and it picks up your
electrical activity from your brain
obviously and then it remembers what
your brain looks like when you're
thinking about a certain thing so every
time you do something different uh a
pattern of brain activity appears for
example one of mine is pushing something
heavy forward and you basically record
you thinking about that for 10 seconds
at a time over and over and over and
over again and it remembers what your
brain activity looks like and then
eventually through machine learning
eventually you can do that pattern of
brain activity and it goes aha oh I know
that that look that picture that I'm
seeing right now that's you pushing
something forward so that's basically
what I've done I've taken a bunch of
those visualizations ations I've trained
it to remember what that is another
really good example she gave me was
healing an Elden ring you can't just
think of the act itself because that can
look like a billion different things but
if you thought of something super
specific like spinning a plate on a
stick a foot in front of you and you got
really really good at visualizing that
the same size plate same speed every
single time well that could be your
trigger for healing an Elden ring and
this wasn't easy for Perry as I
mentioned there was a ton of trial and
error that led to hundreds upon hundreds
of hours of thinking really hard about
random but it paid off every new
input caused new issues but eventually
it started working really really well I
mean she went from left and right in
track Mania to beating
melenia
strength extraordinary it didn't stop
there for Perry either over the course
of 202 3 she expanded her experiments to
tons of other games virtual reality and
even managing to get kills in FPS games
and this year in just a month Perry has
been able to successfully play Super
Smash Brothers without the help of any
supplementary peripherals meaning
literally just her mind she even just
mapped out how to play Power worlds in
what she considers to be her most
complete mind controller
yet I'm going to hit this
rock
right I'm going to
jump now when it comes to what's next
for Perry truly the sky is the limit
when we last spoke Perry told me that
she's continuing to push things even
further introducing new games and a ton
of super secret Tech projects that we
can look forward to in the future
including an actual Esports event using
mind control but what's coolest to me is
that she's still striving to making this
Tech even more accessible so that one
day anyone can use it you see what's
most important to understand about Perry
story is that what she does isn't a
novelty sure seeing someone game without
the use of any controller is pretty cool
but the benefits in accessibility are
nearly Limitless we tend to sometimes
forget that not everyone can experience
video games as a medium accessibility
features get better every single day but
there's still a very long road ahead so
what Perry's working towards removing
the need for a controller and bringing
awareness to the tech involved has the
potential to change the gaming landscape
in ways that are hard to quantify and
honestly I think that's pretty cool I
think it could be such amazing things
for accessibility and and like we say
it's really hard to stick a timeline on
it so potentially like hopefully
hopefully yeah hopefully soon hopefully
one day um and I always feel really
happy grateful to be able to just shine
a little bit of a light on oh this is
technology that's cool and this is what
you could do with it and in gaming or in
anything else just to see if there's
anyone out there who wants to you know
set up the research give the funding to
it so that potentially we could develop
something better that could be used for
accessibility and other other functions
my favorite game to play with my mind
like in like a perfect world I guess
like maybe like if if it's like truly
limit Limitless I would say like Red
Dead Redemption I can just do Westworld
I mean I I'm sure if you ask like a
million people 85% of people would say
like Theft Auto or Red Dead Redemption